hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play I will kill
you okay
I'm not wearing any pants because I know
that I'm about to crap them no I'm just
kidding I'm not wearing any pants cuz
it's comfortable
okay anyway no I want presents dot dot
dot what's behind me a wall all right
then
looks good presents his latest game
creation an indie horror game and a
white wall it is recommended you wear a
headset while playing please add juked
your volume until you can make out the
sounds of foot off footsteps I can hear
them I am NOT responsible for any death
or injury that may come from playing
this game come on left click to interact
use mouse to look around don't let him
find you WASD to move with the darkness
press ENTER to begin all right like as
always find in description if you want
to play for yourself before you see this
I thought I was done full auto put my
door but it bit the end
I'm surprised when I woke up in a
hospital bed a few days later slowly
recovering from my heart failure but
somehow I knew I would be around
football death I thought we got day
he's almost clean to me he'll be back to
finish what he started
and he would kill me who death death
would kill you why would death want to
kill you okay obviously it's been the
same kind of style as on the other
pixelated horror games from gamejolt
this is from games old obviously so room
173 well that's not a good sign given my
previous affiliation getting up won't
help me what what oh no oh my go I was
in a nice room what the hell this isn't
my bed
what's with the heart that is not how
heart space-boats is out what's going on
here hello hello is anybody there what's
going on here I do not like this one bit
hello hmm hey hey now hey stop it I said
stop it I've heard that noise before
somewhere I just don't remember where
some of these games used familiar
I found one key sounds from other games
what does that sound it sounds like
somebody's alright popcorn we're gonna
what's going on what's going on what's
going on
I saw many guillotines geek guillotines
getting louder hello ha what I wanna do
not what the hell was that
alright then getting up won't help me I
should try sleeping no I shouldn't I
shouldn't try sleeping sleeping is a bad
idea alright so I obviously stuck around
for a bit too long looking at the
environment and such he was over here I
believe if it's in the same spot hi yeah
about that okay same key same spot go
through the room with the guillotines
say hi to mr. monster okay
no mr. monster not yet anyway hello is
anybody home
maybe if someone cheese cheese cheese no
I'm assuming sets cheese mmm I like me
some cheese am i we are nah bar now your
son of a [ __ ] I'll kill god damn it
ah you son of a [ __ ] you said there'd
be cheese
I believed you kidding up won't help me
I should try sleeping how many times are
you gonna realize it sleeping is bad
idea is that weird [ __ ] heart Oh
can someone please sing me a song try to
warm this place up a bit some say love
it is a river
bla bla bla bla ha ha ha ha my soul
bleep bleed I don't know
I remember how that song goes the only
reason I know that song is because it's
our family guy ah now go get me I'm not
going that way screw you by God yes stop
it I'm trying here I'm really trying
give me in the same place every single
time I don't know if you're in frame
here behind me
stop it huh wait where where am I now I
know there's a blaze on that king stupid
table I can't get in through there why
are you doing this why are you doing
this to me is this you're killing me is
this what killing me is cuz killing me
doesn't see very good
oh no oh no oh I was in a dark knows
about me don't jump out at me
what is this cutie key gimme good good
I'll get you throw getting you can't
give me when you're gonna chop your own
head off just like that lady my
beautiful princess is now a sham over
herself
I don't know I don't know if he's still
after me but I've got two keys now Oh
one key
I forgot I opened it or did you don't no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no Kevin okay okay go get alive I
know the names Hank of the gamers I will
kill you but do not kill me man
I don't deserve to die whatever that oh
good you're gonna give me he's gonna get
me I'm a dead man dead man walking hey
those eyes weren't there before I mean
the eyes were supposed to be over here
oh why is this screen all flashy thank
you huh know where 0z Go Go Go Go Go Go
Go I'm gonna win I'm gonna win
I know dead end I need a key Oh key how
conveniently play wait a minute
hi you go away you're a douche got it
moving forward got it was it what is
this what is that is that a black key
what was that for why did I get a black
key I know which way I go I don't know
now that I know don't give me don't give
me no give me no give me no give me no
give me no give me no girly dude Joey
nope I refuse I refuse to die get it get
it is there a black door behind here
somewhere
tell you bare I know I talked kind of
spastically when I'm in a high-stress
situation I'm trying it's too kind I
don't know what I'm doing I'm just one
now nod nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope give me around that I can't get
around that oh no oh no oh no oh no he's
gonna get me he's gonna get me
he's gonna get me he's good I don't even
know what he is but he's gonna get me uh
I hope I didn't know that's the other
side of the guillotine is no we're
supposed to be this is not good maybe
he's not gonna give me you know cuz
before he always got me like right as
soon as it's are getting staticky so
maybe maybe the hose the idea maybe I
was just supposed to stress myself out I
heard that what was that yes ears I'm
starting to think that he's not gonna
kept me and that I was just freaking
myself out for no reason because it was
getting staticky I don't know I don't
know I've been in this room before damn
it
damn and I'm gonna be so lost I'm
already so lost
alright no toughen up a bit
Tom see love it
okay that song is not working I'm a
goofy goober yeah you're a goofy goober
yeah well goofy goober yeah I'm back at
the beginning again I'm just checking to
see if there's like a secret black door
of some sort which there is not dammit
where am I going I have no idea I don't
have a map I don't have a waypoint
system I'm totally in the fog here this
was a dead end wasn't it I don't know I
think this is the guillotine room again
isn't it yeah it is I bet here
still don't know what that popcorn
sounding heartbeat is like but I think
that guy nights to see a doctor
I am the doctor do I know what's best
I'm not exactly sure okay hello can I
open you I got a key I have a key
I have a key aha
yes all right moving forward got another
key yes got another key I'm gonna roll
I'm gonna key role I'm at a key grabbing
role yes another one I got a black key -
is that gonna help me
probably not it's getting a bit more
staticky than it was before but now I'm
just going you down a series always
where I don't know where I'm going again
just getting lost I'm just getting more
and more lost what's the point of this
what's the point of this what is that oh
you thank you again hello you again
dead ends dead ends dead ends dead ends
dead ends okay I'm pretty sure that
nothing's gonna happen to me at this
point I think it's just all mind games
stupid mind games it's gotta be some
here it's gotta be man just a long
series of hallways
this game sure knows how to make you
feel stressed I just got this bad
feeling this got my the hairs on the
back of my neck standing up nothing's
happening I'm having I been here before
I don't know anymore my life is a lie
and I'm a big whiny baby where I am a
baby I need to toughen up
take some proneness lessons or something
I swear I've been here before I'm just I
just don't know where okay this is
another dead end with the eyes that I
came in through here and then I went
right where else could I possibly go
this way I guess I feel as if I've been
here before all of this I swear I've
seen it oh well whatever I'm not sure
everything looks the same that's a
problem with this pixelated game I have
no direct oh no not here how did I get
back there oh no this is not good I just
wanted a big circle but I was going
through doors that I'd never seen before
how did I get here ah this leads me back
to the beginning it did damn it how did
I get there I don't even know I'm so
lost I don't know man I don't know what
is this a room full of beds no
see I can't tell if like these sounds
are just getting louder or quieter or or
if it's picking up or if it's going down
oh no it's just this incessant beating
on my head what is the point of all of
this what is the point don't you start
with me now see I don't have a tolerance
for any sort of bull from you aha yeah
yeah uh accident known whoa well Oh
guillotine what are you doing in my room
oh I should have known that something
was up getting up won't help me try
sleeping
don't try sleeping don't sleep man
haven't you learned
sleeping is bad where am I
what is this I can't see anything oh
whoa whoa whoa what the what the hell
that's weird
well that's really weird but I guess I'm
in a series of hallways again just damn
eyes staring at me what are you looking
at what you never seen a guy get lost
and then scared at a scary face before
well you think I'm weird
did somebody pair of eyes okay here's
the black gate okay there's a black gate
easy to find I'm just gonna assume that
the skull is not gonna get me cuz I mean
what's the point what's the point just a
series of tables trying to block my path
huh it's it's not a big truck you can't
just dump it it's a series of tables was
there a point to this
Santa Blackie ah ha ha ha Oh thought you
could hide that from me
well I am too pro for you I am the
greatest now if I could find where the
hell I was cuz I'm not a ha ha ha
don't get me was that just some big joke
who's that some big joke to you am I
just some big joke to you don't you know
who I am my name is markiplier and
welcome to let them know wait my name is
markiplier and I'm not wearing any pants
ding the the initial shock of the game
has died down quite a bit I mean in the
beginning I was in a non-stop panic but
then I quickly realized well in this
very war no no no
Oh calm s can be as you can tell no
reason to panic
Baloo back yeah this is starting to bore
me let's make this a little more more
interest dinga rules are simple don't
let me find you find the light to escape
I've got three keys haha I'm gonna die
what's a bush doing in here this doesn't
make any sense he's gotta go back he's
gonna get me this is I'm the worst at
this game I'm bad at this game this game
is not my game oh no oh no their hand
already now no no no no no no no no no
no no no key Wow ah
Oh game crashed game crashed I will kill
you dot exe oh stop working okay I'm
done for now
heck I don't like that game no I like
that game but oh like that game I don't
like that game I will load you haha
uh hang on let's fire it up again see if
there's something like secret that I
might miss no back in the beginning okay
I'm right hi riff alright so you know
man there was a file that was created in
the folder where I opened the game and
it said I will load you and I'm like
will you now but it didn't so I don't
know you guys find out for yourself it's
pretty good a game as you could tell got
me a hundred hegemon okay anyway so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
Oh
jeez
and stop
but
Oh
uh-oh